that was the biggest like break for me
that i had in a way for my own career
just to be like i'm producing um a
series that's gonna go to tv that's
never been done before
how did you go from an independent
filmmaker to fox creative and production
executive that story starts
on craigslist actually
um when i first moved to los angeles i
was applying for lots of jobs
and didn't know anybody
a lot of those jobs i would apply for on
craigslist and one of them was actually
for an editor um
at fox and
but didn't say where it was from that
was a surprise to me when they wrote
back
anyway i ended up working for them uh as
an editor for uh four years i think and
that was when i was talking earlier
about how
i worked um as an editor and but then i
also was like who's doing the post
and managing all that and then i sort of
was like i'm gonna do it
and nobody ever told me not to um
and i you know once i did it once and it
turned out great we hit our deliveries
and everything came out on budget and it
looked
great for you know very little money
let's say
we would do it again and do it again and
do it again and about that went on for
about
uh four years um on and off of course
and
um i then i went into my my
uh euro uh backpacking trip because i
was like you know like i said i was
working like just too much i needed a
break
and um when i got back i took a job for
directv
and
cutting promos and
producing and directing some of them as
well
which then was bought by att
and
around that time
my former boss at fox that you did a lot
of editorial for
um he was he basically took me to dinner
one day and was like hey i think i have
an
opportunity for you if if you'd be
interested
he had known about my travels and things
like that and
and um was also
a huge soccer fan and
then he kind of basically presented
the project phenoms and that was how i
got involved
there doing uh as a production executive
and really it was mostly post-production
um as well because we had to design
and create
an entire infrastructure for something
that hadn't really been done i mean that
series was
shot in
20 countries for uh almost three years
and it was up to me basically to figure
out how to manage the post-production
for that entire
project that had uh it was a 20 episode
series but five of them were in the u.s
and 15 international episodes also and
coordinating with all the production
teams internationally and it was just a
massive project and i i like to think
that i did a good enough job on those on
the projects that i had worked with him
on previously where i sort of took over
the post-production on things that i was
just editing
uh is what sort of gave him the faith in
my ability to be able to handle that and
it was very stressful because i had
never done something like that big
before
um
but i also uh you know had a great team
and
was able to
uh collaborate and work together with a
bunch of other producers to make all
that stuff happen so
uh but that opportunity came about
because of a relationship and doing a
good job i like to think previously
and so when he asked you to be a part of
it
was there something in you later on that
night that said oh why'd i say yes to
this because you said it would seem
stressful but no no it was more like
holy i mean excuse my french but
like
uh
because you know it wasn't like i just
started the next day i mean there was a
process to get like everything up and
running and
and um it didn't just happen overnight
but
it was definitely an opportunity that i
like absolutely couldn't say no to i
mean that was it was you know that that
series was broadcast um
on fox and fox sports and in like
many many international markets as well
that was the biggest like break for me
that i'd had in a way for my own career
just to be like i'm producing um a
series that's gonna go to tv that's
never been done before
and it also made the editorial very
difficult because
it was also my first time really doing
documentaries
and uh you know you don't have script
but you still have air dates and you
still got to back into those air dates
and make episodes that have stories to
create and with all that material from
all over the world it was just a very
big project but i also
didn't want to to just
you know manage the post-production i
also really was like this this thing is
super cool like i loved it
so i wanted to edit an episode and so
that was part of partially why it was as
stressful as it was for me because i was
handling
a lot at once and i didn't maybe
uh maybe stupidly i i just was like i
need to
play with the creative of this way more
in the weeds than i like than anybody
asked me to do nobody asked me to do
that that was that was for me like
if i'm going to put this all together
and really make all these pieces happen
and
i got to get in there a little bit too
and so um
so that was maybe something that i won't
never do again
just because it was way too demanding um
but i'm glad i did it also once you know
it's it's one of those
i think i had the stamina at the time to
handle it but i i don't think i could do
it again like that exactly it was really
intense like running with the bulls
yeah it was like that it was very
different but like but i but it
definitely felt at times like the whole
thing
uh you know i don't know i mean like
there's so many pieces to that puzzle
that um
that if in post-production that like
always gets affected and so and but you
still like it so it was my
responsibility to um
to get those episodes to air on time
so yeah like needless to say to me i was
like this is my personal responsibility
and if i
uh mess up i'm doomed forever you know i
mean that's how i kind of thought about
it um
and
but again it's like i wasn't alone i had
many many uh
really talented editors and and
um other producers and
helping make all this stuff happen um
and so it wasn't like all on me but i
still put that pressure on myself you
know i'm saying
uh that's maybe just
something that i just do innately
because i i'm like protective and and my
like heart and
um is in the project and that's you know
when i said before like i can get
sometimes obsessive about stuff that's
part of what i mean is
like i'm like this is this is the
biggest thing i've ever done no i you
know it's the only thing it matters and
that you have to talk yourself back from
that a little bit and be like no we're
not curing cancer but it still doesn't
matter and it's still very important
so it's just a balance that
i learned a lot from doing that and what
i do and don't want to do again going
forward but it was an amazing
opportunity and i'm really glad that
that i had it actually
so when you flew back from saint
petersburg russia
you went to go see the game
yeah i went so yeah after after i
delivered all those episodes i went to
to russia for the world cup uh for uh
two or three weeks basically i went to i
went to st petersburg in moscow and we
also had a production team shooting
dur during those years for uh for the
series so i also got to you know meet i
mean it was a really fantastic way to
kind of cap
that three-year journey
what was the flight like back home um
i was kind of ready to be home
by that point
but i have to say that anytime i come
back from a vacation especially one
that's international i do have like a
little period of like depression that i
have to like get out of it's it's it
happens every time honestly it's just
something i'm like used to now it's like
yo you had this amazing experience but
then like
you know you need to kind of rest but
you don't want to
but you don't know what you're doing now
it's like very like that little just
uncertainty period after you get back
and you're like what did it all mean and
uh you know it's part of of how i
have to handle it myself i don't know if
that's the same for everybody but
definitely happens to me
can you explain more about the work that
you did on phenoms so as i mentioned we
uh that series
uh
was shot in 20 countries
and we basically were following 65
of the young
up and coming stars who are trying to
make their national teams for the world
cup
in russia
and
so we had i think
six
maybe eight production teams
internationally shooting with all those
players
and
then
in los angeles we had our
basically
a global series kind of team
which included
my entire office um and eventually
i think at one point we may have had
like 30 editors on this project
including assistant editors and and then
an entire archive team
for
licensing
the material
that we were using as editors
it was a long road though because
we didn't actually start
uh
like the real production on what the
series would become at the be like it
didn't just start that way a lot of it
was you know as a documentary you're
you're sort of like the story has to
kind of unfold in front of you i mean we
had a um
a guide by utilizing the world cup and
and sort of what the goal was
but those players had to tell your tell
their stories they had to either
succeed or fail
um and then
those things would have to be captured
on camera or at least in interviews for
us to all um
find how how best to tell those parts of
the of their stories
and uh keep in mind there's also
language barriers and
uh or many languages uh not barriers but
many languages that were
also editing in
so uh
putting that all together was
a road of
i mean some of it was designed some of
it was um exploratory basically
and
uh it was about six months before we
were the the show was to air and that
was really where we began the episodic
nature of the series we
basically were just kind of cutting
material for a year uh up to that point
just
refining it down like so you know
eight terabytes would come in from
russia and france and so and then that
would go get subtitled uh when necessary
and then logged by the aes and then sent
over to the editorial team which ended
up expanding into another office because
we ran out of space
and then we had to also kind of keep in
mind that all that material had to go
from each location and all be always be
synced it's a lot a lot of technical
stuff that
i'm not sure how much that is really
valuable
to uh to this audience but
it was definitely complicated it's very
technical
um but at the end of the day it was
really just about finding the story that
was that was the pursuit
and um the best way that we found to do
that was to be edit editing
constantly even if we didn't know
it was going to be part of the episode
or not because we had to figure out what
was in the material first
and so it was kind of like draft one you
could say like a script where it's just
your it's your vomit draft it's kind of
if you think about it that way and then
the episodes happened um
and
we also had ancillary content that was
getting created for fox sports uh out of
all that material as well as deliveries
and then i was also editing
uh an episode as well i edited uh the
goalkeepers episode
of the series
and um which i'm you know still is one
of my favorite things i've ever done
honestly it's i'm i'm really uh proud of
of how it turned out and i didn't
actually get a whole lot of
uh notes and things like that like like
i felt like i felt like i had like sort
of cracked something and uh to the point
where like
you know i kind of got left alone a
little bit more uh than i was used to
which was excellent for me but also kind
of like well what do you think about
this like come on guys tell me like you
know i mean there were so many other
things to go like going on at the time
that were you know logistic uh you know
like my post coordinator like did a
fantastic job i mean like a lot of those
people that came in really
really brought everything together to
make that show happen i mean it doesn't
happen
um
it was such a post-heavy
project too that
i'm you know i'm very glad that that my
boss at the time
you know trusted me to do it but
if i could if if you had asked me in the
beginning did i would did i would i have
known that that we were going to be able
to pull it off i wouldn't have been able
to
tell you honestly but i would have said
yes because
why not i mean like we have to figure it
out together and that's part of the part
of the process
so it's also money related and so many
other things too well and you had these
air date deadlines that you were
fighting against too yes yeah we knew
exactly when they were going to air
probably like six months out i think
which was basically the
the the first
the three
fridays leading up to the world cup the
one thing that really that really hurt
that series at least in my opinion was
the fact that the us didn't make the
world cup
and that was just something that none of
us could have like expected i mean i i
think that it was like 12 years befo uh
since the the us hadn't made
the the world cup by that point so it
was a big surprise to all of us and
really kind of i remember that there was
probably like a two-week period in there
where we were really like a little
worried about what that meant for the
series at least in the us i guess um
that that episode though that covers the
u.s um
uh disqualification is fantastic it was
cut by a good friend of mine and it's
devastating to watch like because it was
so
much a part of
at least our culture i don't know about
the entire country because
i think it was like um
you know it wasn't as big of a deal as
if we were in it of course but um but
i'm a huge fan of the game and so it was
very much a big
like passion project for me that i had
a lot of people that were also like huge
fans um
involved in the project i mean that's
the only reason i even got made is
because people love that game
and sorry why was the u.s disqualified
oh they just didn't win they didn't they
didn't make it they didn't uh they
didn't they didn't qualify for the world
cup i see it okay so they were
disqualified in that sense so there was
no scandal it was just that no no yeah
they just they just didn't play well
enough
and so it was a devastating result
you